[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talked about I'm not confident
enough to sing with you guys nice oh
come on why yeah please don't have a
good voice no play you're still doing
the thing again no not because I really
voices so that's a Pavarotti you think
you're feeding into it
Oh am i yes nope I'm gonna keep talking
to explain because I don't know that
exactly what he wanted to hear him do
ASMR literally spoon feeding his ego ass
do it well why did you bring up singing
what's happening you guys because I do
whatever I just stared the camera why
don't you say whatever we want to I
might mess it up
you never say it he feels I did it once
like a few episodes back and he felt
weird about it yeah I was like oh wait a
few more months it's okay you can play
with us no I can't I'm not even
officially part of the cast and I like I
do it you've been on here more than I
have yeah it's true
you're grandfathered in bro I know I
know you're an honorary guest meant more
like I'm gonna back up you Billy Jay
case for overt like 12 10 years I know
that we know each other for a really
long time consume come no [ __ ] who's
next
yeah I had a threat guess we'll have to
make to hear more [ __ ] oh to hear more
here that's what I was going for not
actually after to hear I love to hear
yeah but you'd love to hear what
everyone knows it Wow including him
damn we text we talk Larry three people
and then outside of these three people
everyone else is a backup okay
am i back up you're definitely a backup
your sidearm what about me says oh
that's a company oh we miss your
firepower girls you're [ __ ] a nuclear
[ __ ] bomb bro yeah see she's fishing
too but
because she deserves it no no you
deserve a Julia but yeah so you can't
sing I can't I try and then I might see
something I know no see mary had a
little lamb
oh I can't yeah it'll be like that scene
in Sister Act to which one people think
mary had a little lamb you never see the
second sister I love sister
Oh tip I do think the first one is
better than the second one I mean they
they're dope in different ways both
Whoopi and Lauren Hill bra I've only
seen the first one so you've never seen
that Oh Timmy wants the same movies
growing up sister Mary Clarence raised
me last time
diplomacy sorry so cute we're gonna say
Diplo raised me Timmy came here today
he's like that and I what and the thing
is like I didn't think anybody would get
the reference except for Steve yeah yeah
yeah so y'all should really watch this
track - it's like it's so good and lead
- welcome to as well I mean yeah sure it
has a the chick from hook in it Sister 2
Sister 2 Sister hook the Peter Pan the
the grand matriarch of the whole nun
convention is the Wendy yo old Wendy old
one yes yes yeah any lady was there a
young Wendy in hook no there wasn't
there was no young Wendy that Oh Oh coz
pan win oh that's right that's how he
was old pan so anyway one of your best
friend's is Dante Bosco but whatever you
don't mean all the hooks acts been a
long time since I've seen hook it's been
a while for me to actually haven't seen
done day like two years
oh we last saw him in Vegas was it a yes
yeah oh you were there did he release
was two years
it was think about it just like running
to him or you just went with him yeah
well he was there with my buddy rod hi
I'm Ron from youtube and then they are
business partners somehow cuz know so
many people some weird business thing
has a popular but Dante's dope yeah
they're working on my Filipino films and
stuff yeah yeah we were supposed to do
one you know why write somewhere no in
the Philippines oh you wanted to shoot
like a giving too much away like almost
like a an Asian Filipino bad boy
situation we're me and him are cops cert
and I'm like girl let's do this [ __ ]
soon before like you know well let me
know so I can kind of get toned and also
like you know we're getting a little old
with Kimmy running around and [ __ ] when
we're old so let's Jackie is older than
you and you think you are how do you
smoke no I was talking about Dante
things they should do and like try once
at least you know what I mean no like
other things are a little bit safer like
meth yeah by the crack horn horn there
you got it like being paid to kiss on
camera hahaha there's talk about that
that's so interesting
guys listen how do we make this for you
guys this is like the fifth video we're
about to talk about yes [ __ ] do it
you're not gonna get anything you two
better suck a double-sided dildo or
something
this is what your mistake was your
mistake was asking me what I felt like
was it we did you [ __ ] this so
frustrated because you two are literally
like sisters to me why don't you suck a
double-sided dildo on camera Oh what was
gonna be cheaper you have to be inserted
what a good attitude I was your chick
star like that
wait so what's the price huh it's way
cheap when they say I think it's like
ten dollars yeah this is really cheap so
you guys too sick of talking about this
around okay okay what are your feelings
on that what something uh it's just
funny a thing right now who gives [ __ ]
really know what it's like you hold a
woman to on a higher pedestal which i
think is good but you do things for her
so say it's like there's a girl that
you're trying to get out right so you're
like oh she's gonna get I want to get a
lot I'll get you one and hoping and
you'd be like nice and buy her things
like just be super nice - we're gonna
buy her love yeah calling guys who
opened doors man I know just like a
super whip like bend over backwards but
it's like almost like like you're kind
of like her little like your shearling
like do whatever you want what about if
like the boyfriends that do the
Instagram photos for her - the chicks
innocent that's what they say online so
basically I use them like her yours huh
well if you're a piece of [ __ ] then
you're not a simple that's what the [ __ ]
there are the kids yeah made it is
actually here's what annoys me the most
about sim is this an old-ass word is it
really [ __ ] old like from the 70s and
she well I [ __ ] up with that [ __ ]
because I remember bar was like all this
guy's too much cloud I'm not using cloud
now he's a good cop spin around
yeah well clouds been around it with
club club it's a it's a stain remover
right yeah it works
Oh shouts cuz I remember so check this
out when I was in the high when I was in
when I was working at Foot Locker at the
mall there was a girl that I was trying
to talk to who worked that hot dog on a
stick
okay and she was are they always so hot
by the way
it's little outfits yeah yeah so she was
so cute and we started talking was she
white no she was she's black I just work
that I'm Mexican I see a lot of me well
I mean it's a Mexican neighborhood that
make sense yeah so so the other visual
little caramel complected Hot Dog on a
Stick employee and and she was sick so I
one day I am I brought to be cute I
bought her a [ __ ] little Campbell's
soup can right I brought it to her here
you go cuz he told me you were sick
right so she then that night she's like
yeah so I told my dad that you brought
me a can of soup cuz I was sick and my
dad goes oh so he's a simple so that's
how old this word is isn't that kind of
bad because as a dad you want your dad
called me a simple being nice to his
daughter
we lap around the other dates right
that's just a weird ideology there I
don't understand it
yeah but I also do get I guess so I
don't know what we're gonna draw the
line or whatever but I also do get where
if guys that bend over backwards
completely and they're trying to buy the
love and then it's almost like there's
no the relationships no longer 50/50
it's more like ninety ten I also get
that - you're like almost in a sense
friend-zoning yourself yeah but it's
like you're you're letting you're
basically making her take advantage of
you yeah like a nice guy times like 10
yeah it's a too nice guy yes that's the
problem and they're really looking for
something else which is not even genuine
which cancels out trying to [ __ ] the
whole time those are sins yeah but yeah
but they're so nice if you got to give
them the chance because they're so nice
I hate if I'm working an angle so give
me a break will you I also think maybe
the people that are cuz like to me
whatever is happening between people's
relationships that's their thing right
so you let them be there thrive in
whatever if they don't want to be in it
they'll try to get out of it
so the people that I feel like are
calling people simps or is that like a
projection like they see they they feel
yucky because they see their symp self
and them if you have to talk about
anyone online you're insecure look it's
dude when we were kids it's the same
[ __ ] like our teenagers
like why everyone called each other gay
epithets because everyone's like trying
to front and be like oh I'm not that gay
and all this stuff like it's it's all
what is that you know the f-word no he
said he's saying what's an epithet
epithet it's like a bad bad thing to say
about somebody like a yeah well I think
from like nowadays the kids calling each
other stamps it's more of a joke okay oh
you got that girl flowers sip yeah it's
almost like people you'd be like you
know you say you did something for a
girl and back then you go oh I'm Shh oh
he's whipped [ __ ] like this you know I'm
saying it's more it's more just like a
internet troll situation chocolate on
down Thursday what'd it say yeah yeah
yeah we're talking about this girl with
my roommates and they're obviously
joking but they're yeah I just want to
get them in trouble okay
but um basically like they're like
showing me this girl that's like one of
our friends and she's like super hot and
then she's like she has a [ __ ] ton of
followers who is she who is she
you can't say is it Amanda Cerny no no
but basically then I was like oh but
like she also has a personality and
that's how her and it's not a miniature
me this show heavy you Steven I know I
didn't move my feet are so pretty she's
so funny yeah she said we don't love it
but where'd you kiss her our camera $10
well they called me a cent for saying
that she had a personality
oh yeah for real and they meant it or no
no it was [ __ ] around
what she does but that's what happens
online huh does she does she does well
your roommates called you a sip online
they didn't just tell you in person
no in prison I'm saying I'm saying
because they're just in that culture of
just making fun of online people bring
it into real life oh they're making fun
of that all night coach by calling music
that's what I see because they're smart
they're like they're they're trolling
the first thing it's equivalent to like
if you you know if you like hug the
homie and someone goes gay like that
type of thing it's me Maria
yeah yeah I wouldn't say it was I'm just
out for two girls in this room two kids
I would call thank you we're calling gay
no I call it lesbian let it go
that's me honors okay hey brick green
let it go okay let it go anyway if we
get 20 commenting this video if we get
20 comments with 100 likes we guys do we
get our payment full that's not that
amount let's restart GoFundMe or
refunding the space it's much so you
guys are all in relationships right
mm-hmm for someone like me good comments
in no I'm just saying for meeting girls
online I'm jamming them I'm doing stuff
like that it's a dick pic sending nude
saying dick pics right just that the
casual the first message to them is
usually a picnic right well no wonder
you're getting late I know but uh what's
uh besides that what's like the proper
way to slide into a DM that you guys
think cuz I've done ones where I've
literally taking a block of ice in the
video and smashed it and then sent them
that video and the icebreaker is so far
yeah but Q that was they loved it
did you have you ever gone face-first on
a slip and slide I'm sliding into your
hands that's good yeah you put like D
and my crocodile mine yeah into a DM a
what crocodile mile that's what the
yellows up inside at the end of it was
always a crocodile with his mouth open
so you go through his mouth yeah
to get into I'd know what that thank you
very much that's called white trash
history yeah more people know about it
you should hold a segment okay well I
would but everyone took down the
crocodile mouth statue recently yeah
what a white history forever and then
they took it down so if if you receive
that right you'd never heard of that
before like a guy doing that and you
kind of had an attraction for the guy
would you enjoy that would you find out
Q would you find that funny but I'll
that's lame
but I took the effort to make that well
you also probably have a bunch of other
guys in a jam but did you make it for
them or did you make it for general use
around general use they don't know that
they do know that that's the problem
still relevant still cute regardless how
would y'all reply to that dude honestly
every time I think about these dating
scenarios I'm like that's such a foreign
world
no that's not helping me right now sorry
I'm letting you know that I don't think
I'm very helpful okay I'm just saying if
you got that right now you're single
well [ __ ] it can't even imagine being
single I don't think one of those 15
[ __ ] I hear so many girls say they're
like so sick of guys like saying the
same old [ __ ] so when they come with
something cute or unique then it's like
oh okay
this is this is interesting I will reply
this yes I mean I would think it would
be funny but I can't imagine myself
being in that scene I think I'll be too
nervous to be in that scene you see
where you thought the theme yeah sorry
finally use yeah I think we know what
this is actually dammit oh man I'm gonna
work right it worked
yeah I've done twice yeah same exact
video doing that video but you still
said this morning that you're still sad
about girls so you're sad about girls I
still aside I can be sad please be sad
yeah you said that you were has it
worked out well that's being sad for no
no the girl a situation no so the thing
is the girls aren't from California
all right see this isn't the stock one I
feel like what I don't like doing the
dating app because there's just so much
[ __ ] time I'm on there too it's like
with that I'm horrible text so I can't
get my purse on if they're just like I
don't wanna deal with this then how do
you talk to the people outside of
California because now it's all texts
are you facetiming them uh well at least
like the first initial right that's why
I came up with the video yeah that's me
yeah you're like hey cutie no he's like
hey breaking the ice you should I mean
that's not a not a joke it's not this
you should send to these girls because
they actually know and they like you and
they want to help you and like so like
ah I have friends of ours who send me
stuff before they send it to guys just
to screen it a little bit and I think
that's good oh no I'm like a hundred
percent oh yeah I totally support that
even though it might be a bad idea
that's the problem because that's happen
when me and Geo hmm so I would tell geo
hot girls that I liked because were
friends before for three years this is
what I would like was what I want to do
I'm like there's this sort of my
favorite musician back those names
Cascades like a DJ but what if I burned
this CD on a first date and I'm just
roll down their nose and we cruise
around soon and then we're having a
really good time and she's like oh that
would be so awesome we get into the car
this girl's [ __ ] hair is flying all
over the [ __ ] place she's like oh I'm
really cold and I'm driving on like
giotto miss would be a great idea and
then it was just so every everything
that she thought was dope because I
think like when you're talking to a
friend or a homegirl
there's no weird wall so they're really
looking at what you're pitching as what
it is yeah but when a girl is dating you
or whatever there's already like okay is
this [ __ ] as thirsty as the
other five guys yes so there's this
thirst thing going on and then so
there's there extra defensive so things
don't really work out that well girls
also aren't a monolith just like anybody
else
true all girls don't agree on everything
nature the idea though is that you at
least get some pre-screening like advice
and you can decide for yourself no the
worse that is because to me I'm like I
want I want to support you and you
achieving your dreams so [ __ ] it if you
if you like if your heart is in it I'm
gonna [ __ ] like yeah I know but I'm
not asking for that I know you're gonna
be down the hey what do you think about
this that's so [ __ ] tight look if I
let me send a video of my penis there
might be in it or something like that so
[ __ ] tight not it if you give me a
meaningful message behind you setting
this chick laters your picture of your
penis or a video of your penis I'll be
like damn a Nadeem that's [ __ ] deep
yeah yeah so your deep dick is in the
shop get indeed standing over his dick
it's like yeah no no dude no put some
ice on the table break the ice with your
dick oh my goodness next level yeah hey
like I'm not really good at saying these
things by just wanna let you know every
time I see you or think about you blood
rushes into my penis and it makes it
very hard I think so romantic a good one
yeah I would marry you water yeah it's
hard see so everybody thought you were
simple tip associate you enjoy that I
said hey based off the boobs and ass
that I see in the picture they post the
word boobs really gets me that yeah I
can tell that you have a great
personality there's a really cool that's
actually personality I'm out but that's
actually really funny I think that's a
good opener to to be honest like yo I
saw your boobs and your butt I think you
probably have a great personality like
what's up
funny enough to get a reply hey I see
you have two boobs are you probably
Gemini honestly though it really boils
down to what kind of girl you want to
get and you attract that girl yeah
that's what I'm saying like this is a
crazy idea we'll just be yourself
and then maybe I'll click with the girls
that matched what you want versus you
trying to play the game what you think
then it never works
you guys send us away you would slide it
into our DMS but they're all cheap
married and would send it to me I don't
have confidence for that [ __ ]
breaking ice with your coochie lips I
feel table and break it up with no Julia
and tip putting ice between their lips
in the minute crushing them by making
out pretty hard
interesting I think that's fastening no
no no be my what was it was it was a
colonist only fans or family only since
- I'll be your own hands man I'll be my
like but you're gonna make out with tip
no yeah ready for this video and 15
seconds ago Julia's only fans man how do
you talk we either have some discussions
Tyler I have a slant or DM is there a
term called handsy
[Music]